Karin starts off of this hour with us in
North Carolina hi Karen
welcome to the show hi Dave how are you
today better than I deserve what's up in
your world okay so my husband and I have
a car fleece that we're trying to get
out of I want to pay it off in our debt
snowball and he wants to trade it into a
dealership have them pay it off and then
move down in car and pay off that loan
so my question is why why is his idea
not a good one
well the question is are you gonna move
far enough down in car when you do that
I mean so what's the car that you're
driving what's the sticker price on it
or what's it worth or something so it's
it's well to get out of the lease
it's twenty-five thousand to buy it
outright and what would you move down to
well I don't know exactly but something
way under that for sure
what's way under way under mama is
$5,000 whoa okay well again this is this
is his idea I just want to take it off
in the debt snowball but he thinks his
way would get us out of debt sooner so
probably something just a couple of
thousand dollars less I would think yeah
well if your movie you know the further
you move down the more his idea would be
accurate I mean you know the faster
you're going to get out of debt because
you're getting rid of more and more debt
right right that makes sense
so yeah I think I think that's a good
idea possibly
so 25,000 and what is that car worth do
you think well trade-in value is 21 to
23 and private party is more of course
about 24 to 26 okay so it's a you could
probably sell it for about what it takes
to get the you know
pay it off roughly right right okay so
what is your household income um 150
okay
what's the other car worth dinner cars
worth nineteen thousand and how much
other debt other than your home do you
guys have twenty five on this leased car
and what else it's just the two paying
off the other car at nineteen which is a
loan and then this fleece that's your
only debt no student loan no credit card
no nothing else no we're a baby step two
and we've paid off two credit cards
and note student loan okay and so
basically what we're saying is $44,000
makes you debt-free and you make a
hundred and fifty correct
okay our rule of thumb is this don't own
cars or anything with wheels and motors
added together that equals more than
half your annual income because things
with wheels and motors all go down in
value and if you've got too much tied up
in boats and tractors and sea-doos and
motorcycles and cars that all go down in
value then you are obviously going to
have trouble building wealth right you
have not violated that you're not over
half your annual income with these two
cars okay the second rule of thumb that
we use is can you be a hundred percent
debt-free
except your home inside of two years and
the answer is yes you could you could
pay off forty four thousand and you're
sleep in two years making 150 and not
affect you I'll do it in one year so do
you like the car that has the fleece on
it no not really
we don't okay so you're probably trading
it anyway yeah okay well what I would do
is pay off the 19 thousand our car as
soon as possible in just a few months
and then I would get about the business
of trading that car for whatever it is
you want to drive that is around that
same price range and just do it on a
loan
and then turn around pay that off I
don't I don't have a problem with you
guys driving cars that are worth $45,000
when you make a hundred and fifty if
they're paid for okay and so if you want
to be in that price range I see no
reason for you to move to a five
thousand dollar car
I would rather you cut your lifestyle
get on a tight budget watch what's going
on you know punch this thing in the face
and get it done and keep some reasonable
cars for a family that makes $150,000
exactly yeah cuz if you move down to a
$5,000 car as soon as you get out of
debt the first thing you're gonna do
start saving to move into a better car
because you make a hundred fifty
thousand and driving a five thousand our
car is unreasonable you can't remove
backup right with cash so why not just
pay this one off quickly and keep it or
paid something like it off that you like
and to keep it so if you want to trade
fine don't trade up you don't have to
trade down much but trade into a loan
out of a fleece and then turn and pay
both of these things off inside of one
year that's what I would do if I were in
your shoes took me a minute to get all
the pieces gathered up but that finally
got there my fault thanks for calling